the closed beta of watson orchestrate
the trust radius 2022 best of awards and
a forester report naming ibm as a
digital process automation leader all on
this episode of ibm cloud now
what's up y'all my name is ian and i am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements from ibm
cloud
we're so glad to be back with you in
2022 we've got a bunch of great stuff
lined up for you in the next few
episodes
to kick things off today i want to let
you know about the availability of our
watson orchestrate closed beta
now covet lockdowns increased customer
expectations and changes in workforce
demographics have led to skyrocketing
investments in digital transformation
technology
to put it plainly today's labor
shortages demand a dramatic shift in how
workers engage with automation
watson orchestrate digital employees
will allow your workforce to meet the
unique needs of today's business
challenges
digital employees differ from rpa bots
or simple chat bots by using ai
technology to dynamically select the
skills needed to complete series of
tasks and workflows
this means they can sequence multiple
skills at once to complete more complex
workflows on the fly digital employees
are the future of how we interact with
our applications accomplish work and
rethink our business processes to learn
more and sign up for the beta of watson
orchestrate click the link below
next up
i'm thrilled to announce that several
solutions by ibm have won in various
categories of the trust radius 2022 best
of awards
the trust radius awards have become an
industry standard for unbiased
recognition of b2b technology products
and they are based entirely upon
customer feedback
the ibm power system s922 solution and
the ibm robotic process automation
solution both won in three categories
best relationship best value for price
and best feature set additionally the
ibm power system s924 server and the ibm
power systems virtual server both won in
two categories best relationship and
best feature set
ibm is honored to receive these awards
and will continue to work diligently to
surpass our clients needs to see more
about the awards hit the link below
and finally to wrap things up today i'm
also excited to announce that ibm cloud
pack for business automation has been
named a digital process automation
leader in the latest forrester wave
report
the forester report cites the strengths
of the cloud pack for business
automation in decisioning document
automation and content management
it also notes ibm's attention to driving
innovation with strong analytics and
artificial intelligence
if your organization is looking for ways
to automate core operations improve
productivity and take advantage of
analytics and deep learning
ibm cloud pack for business automation
can help click the link below to learn
more and read the report
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of ibm cloudnow if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics i've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description in
this video
and again please don't forget to
subscribe to our channel to stay up to
date on what's going on in the cloud now